the tile of Romina has become a
battleground hundreds of students took
to the streets on Monday following weeks
of protests provoked by allegations of
racism in Papua province government
offices shops and homes were set on fire
before Indonesian forces fired tear gas
to disperse protesters kiosks were burnt
killing some people trapped inside agile
the provincial capital students were
ordered to leave Chandra Wasi university
police accused some students of
attacking security forces with rocks
Monday's riots are reported to have
started after a teacher racially abused
a student because government does not
respond to the PAP ones at all the
army's response is to cross all Paquin's
calls for human respect Indonesia's
police chief is blaming the violence on
the separatist movement in West Papua
what happened in Java and Papua are
connected it was planned by a certain
group in time for the UN General
Assembly in one minha there was a plan
by the separatist movement to set up a
hoax
there was no humiliation tensions have
been brewing in Papua for weeks
following various allegations of racial
and ethnic discrimination last month
security forces fired tear gas in a
university dormitory and arrested
students for vandalizing the national
flag the unrest dates back to 1963 when
the UN declared Indonesia could take
control of West Papua if its people
agreed in a referendum but only a
thousand people voted yes many pop when
said the result was rigged and demanded
independence that's caused decades of
fighting between separatists and
Indonesian government forces the
government have been president Joko we
should consider to start the dialogue if
the Indonesia is worried about let's say
Papua but actually dialects to the
opposition's to the pro-independence
movement
groups 6000 security personnel have been
sent to quell the rioting around 400
suspects are being questioned in Papua
following the unrest and internet access
has been blocked in Romania and Jaya
pora aimed at curbing further protests
government leaders in the capital say
the situation is under control but the
latest use of force is threatening to
aggravate tensions further in Papua
Rahila mohamed al jazeera jakarta